examine more closely this determination
of n lies just as much in the notion of
the thing that of being in its own self
an end that is to say it preserves
itself that is it is at one and the same
time its nature to conceal the necessity
and to exhibit it in the form of a
contingent relation for its freedom or
its being for self is just this to treat
the necessity of the relation as of no
importance thus it presents itself is
something whose notion falls outside of
its being similarly reason has a
necessity to look on its own notion as
falling outside of it hence as a thing
as something towards which it is
indifferent and which is therefore
reciprocally and different towards
reason and it's notion as instinct
reason also remains at the level of mere
being and a state of indifference and
the thing expressing the notion remains
for it's something other than this
notion and the notion other than the
thing thus for reason the organic thing
is in its own self and end only in the
sense that the necessity which presents
itself is hidden in the action of the
thing for this behaves as an indifferent
being for self falls outside of the
organism itself since however the
organism as an end in its own self
cannot behave in any other way than as
an organism the fact that it is an end
in itself is also manifest and present
in sensuous fashion and it is as such
that it is observed the organism shows
itself to be a being that preserves
itself that returns and has returned it
to itself but this observing
consciousness does not recognize in this
being the notion of end or that the
notion of end exists just here and in
the form of a thing and not elsewhere in
some other intelligence it makes a
distinction between the notion of end
and being for self and self preservation
a distinction which is none
that it is in fact no distinction is
something of which this consciousness is
not aware on the contrary the making of
the distinction appears to it as a
contingent act having no essential
connection with what is brought about by
that act and the unity which links the
two together that is the said act and
the end falls asunder for this
consciousness
here in paragraph 259 we're really in
the heart of the observing reason
section and I want to remind us of
something the observing goes both ways
there's sort of a ambiguity that might
even be intentional if we want a tribute
it to Hegel because what we're looking
at is reason as a motive consciousness a
shape of consciousness and as it is
observing in this case the organism and
the the end right but we're also
ourselves as the readers following along
with Hagel the phenomenologist we are
observing that reason that is carrying
out this observation so there's a
duality of perspective here reason in
this sense is seeing things in a certain
way and Hagel will tell us what it's
actually not grasping and this is going
to continue through several paragraphs
but we're seeing what is being missed or
left out so we have a fuller picture
then does the observing reasonable
observing reason is where the real
action is so he begins this paragraph by
saying examine more closely this
determination of end lies just as much
in the notion of the thing that a being
in its own self end we just saw in the
previous paragraphs how an organism
doesn't merely have a teleological
relation in the sense of being given an
end external to it if he has its own
teleology you know implicit in its own
being made explicit through what Abel
calls action in a tune or taught
sometimes be two different you know uses
verb noun and the end of the organism
is to continue its own existence and if
possible to want to match its own
existence it does so in relation to its
other which is its environment right so
hey old is going on with destiny says it
preserves itself it is in it is at one
at the same time its nature to conceal
the necessity and to exhibit it in the
form of a contingent relation so that is
what we've got right here so the
organism is related to nature and it has
a given degree of freedom of being for
self that is it's not necessarily self
conscious in a discursive way that we
might point to but it is aware of how
his environments and the things of its
environment the objects that it engages
with effective and it has certain things
you know you know certain responses and
these responses are not just blind dumb
instinctual things it has a certain
degree of freedom in what it does now
this freedom is not what we would call
the freedom of choice in the sense of
why am I spell out for myself option a
and then I spell up for myself option B
and I ponder a while which of these
options shall I pursue Hagel is not
saying that it's that sort of freedom
but it does have the capacity to to be
greater than what is impinging upon it
you might say what is determining it and
so on the organism itself is expressing
a kind of internal necessity in its
relation to nature which is also you
know where the organism itself is right
so we work out here is sort of an
unfolding through its own action but it
displays this as contingent contingent
to who to the organism no because the
organism is not perfect you know all
that worried about necessity and
contingency the organism is concerned
with eating calculating laying in the
Sun staying a lot
all sorts of things so who is this you
know determination of contingency or
necessity important for it's not for the
organism it's for observing reason right
observing reason is interested in the
difference between these because
observing reason wants to in a certain
way master the organism make it its own
because it thinks that the whole world
is for as we see alright so he goes on
any sense its freedom where it's being
for self is just this to treat the
necessity of the relation is no
important so it presents itself is
something whose notion falls outside of
its being all right so the notion of
organism lies outside of the being of
the organism except perhaps for reason
which can grasp it now notice what he's
going to say here there's a similar
mirroring going on reason looks at the
the organism and perhaps says all the
silly bastards they have no idea what
they're doing those little hoppy frogs
jumping around eating the Flies you know
avoiding herons etc etc etc right reason
doesn't realize that in itself is
involved in doing something quite
similar so that's what we have up here
he goes on he says reason he has a
necessity to look at on its own notion
as falling outside of it hence as a
thing so we've got here is a sort of
triadic relation between reason which is
itself
hearing out an action reason Hagel's say
also at this point is unfolding itself
in terms of its instinct it is not yet
what we might call critical reason right
it's not reason at its full extent but
it's it's pretty powerful it's more
powerful than the other organisms and
what they did so reason he says looks at
its own notion is falling outside of it
a thing something towards which it is
indifferent and which is therefore
reciprocally indifferent towards reason
and it's notion so what does this mean
he tells us in the next section reason
remains at the level of mere being and
state of indifference and the thing
expressing the notion remains for it's
something other than this notion and the
notion other than this thing we have a
schism here between the notion yeah the
thing and what we're seeing here is the
very beginnings reason attempting to
notice what it is itself engaged in and
to become more self conscious now where
this is going to get developed is
primarily going to be in a later section
it's not not in this section itself that
Hagel is pointing this is out to us this
important development so he says for
reason the organic thing is its own self
is in its own self an end only in the
sense that the necessity which presents
itself is hidden from the action of the
thing for this behaves is in a different
being for so falls outside of the
organism itself the necessity seems not
to be there in the organism so where is
a necessity you over here are the notion
of the organism right he goes on and he
says so the organism as an end in its
own self cannot behave in any other way
that is an organism the fact that it is
an end in itself is also manifest in
sensuous fashion and it is such that it
is observed so observing reason takes in
what is not hitting the organism
displaying itself to be a net but in the
way that it does so is through what it
actually does that's observable not the
what we might call hidden teleology by
which we can explain why it's doing what
it's doing so you know to make this very
concrete I brought up frogs let me as an
example actually from my childhood we
had frogs in a cage and we would feed
them flies this is back in back in grade
school and everything wouldn't wait
until winter time because in Wisconsin
winter you don't have an awful lot of
lots as a matter of fact mostly at Six
Day and normally what a fraud would do
is hiring it during winter right there's
no food supply it can't keep itself
alive you know there's no no flies to
reproduce its environment becomes in a
certain sense what was a good
environment for it a warm environment
becomes a hostile environment because
now it's going to lack its sustenance
right so now think about this in terms
of teleology the the organism the frog
has a desire to perpetuate a knit self
in existence in relation to its
environment it would do so if it were
cool enough by highbury it can't do that
and it also can't do what it would like
to do with its environment which is so
you know shoot its tongue out it flies
and eat them up we used to catch flies
and put them in some frogs cage and he
told our teacher hey you gotta like put
this frog maybe he had a cool spot like
in the basement so I can hibernate
he insisted no we're not going to do
that I think perhaps you want to see
what would happen the Frog became more
and more skeletal and eventually died
now how does it how does that fit in
here what did we actually observe with
our senses we saw the frog in skinnier
we saw a lack of flies if you can see a
lack with your senses we we sense the
heat putting all that together requires
going somewhat beyond the senses about
things that are grasped through the
senses you don't see the teleology the
same way that you see a frog shoot its
tongue out and you know consume the fly
but you do cognize the teleology through
observation the teleology involved in in
this this particular organism I might
say for the fly you know terrible
teleology right doesn't want to be so he
goes I only says the N visit itself
manifest and President sensuous fashion
as such it's observe the organism shows
itself to be a being that preserves
itself that returns and has returned it
to itself but this observing
consciousness does not recognize in this
being the notion of that or that the
notion event exists just here in the
form of a thing we have it again the
notion of the organism as end the notion
of reason itself as end is not being
wrapped not as such so he says i exist
here in the form of a thing now else
wearing some other intelligence it makes
a distinction between the notion of end
and being for self and self preservation
this is a distinction which is not hail
old saying you know you can distinguish
between teleology the notion of end and
the action of self-preservation but they
really are connected with each other so
he says then
that it is in fact a distinction is
something of which is consciousness is
not aware so this is where we are you
might say up here right we're not on the
chalkboard looking in unreason as it's
looking at everything else what are we
talking about here we're talking about
what we observe when we ourselves are in
this mode of reason what we observed
when we see other people doing this in
the present we're also talking about the
development that took place of
consciousness in the past so he says
that it is in fact notice tension is
something of which is consciousness not
where I'm a contrary the making of the
distinction appears to it as a
contingent act having no essential
connection with what is brought about by
that act the unity which links the two
together the act and the end falls
asunder for this consciousness what we
have here is consciousness not truly
recognizing its own self it as it's
working out the you know what reason is
in relation of the world through reasons
distinctive action guided by its
instinct shoe ality
on this view what belongs to the
organism itself is the action lying in
the middle between its first and last
stage so far as this action bears with
it at the character of singleness so far
however is the action as the character
of universality and the agent of the
action is equated with the outcome of
that action purpose of action as such
would not belong to the organism that
single action which is only a means
comes through it singleness under the
category of an altogether single or
contingent necessity what an organism
does to preserve itself as an individual
or as a genus is therefore as regards
this immediate content quite
uncontrolled by any law for the
universal and the notion fall outside of
it accordingly its activity would be an
empty activity devoid of any content of
its own it would naughty not be even the
activity of a machine for this had a
purpose and its activity there for a
specific content deserted in this way by
the universal it would be the activity
merely of something in media qua
immediate that is an activity like that
of an acid or base which is not at the
same time reflected into itself an
activity which could not separate itself
from its immediate existence nor give up
this existence which gets lost in the
relation to its opposite and still
preserve itself but the thing whose
activity is under consideration here is
posited as a thing that preserves itself
in its relation to its opposite the
activity is such as nothing but the pure
essence list form of its being for self
in its substance which is not merely a
determinate being but the universal or
its end does not fall outside of it it
is an activity which spontaneously
returns into itself and has not turned
back into itself by anything alien to it
in paragraph 260 Hagel is continuing
this this watching how observing reason
makes sense out of the organism in terms
of teleology in particularly here in
terms of action what he's going to show
us here is you might say two sides of
action that are being split off from
each other two different perspectives
and he's dwelling on on the one here
that seems to be in many respects of a
philosophical perspective less promising
but he's doing so to try to show us what
happens when we take a universal and
concept in a galleon concept or notion
basically gratefully way of looking at
things out of the picture so he talks in
terms of a first and it's translated
here in Miller's for a stage but it's
just air stuff and last that stuff and
then in between them you might say
mediating them going from first to last
is is the action right so it says on
this view it belongs to the organism
itself what belongs to the organism is
the the action although the first is
also the organism the last is also the
organism it's the action that is that is
combining them you might say mediating
between the two stages the action and I
should put this this way the action
really you might say from a teleological
perspective encompasses them because
what is the the organism doing it is
maintaining its own being as hagel it is
said in previous paragraphs there's a
necessity that was there from the
beginning and is being unfolded right
what's with their what appears is what
was already there so you know that he
says this action bears within it the
character is singleness that's what
makes it lie in between here that's
where we get to something
really interesting so what are we
talking about with this character of
singleness and character universality so
in action is always in a certain respect
in an ontological way individual action
singular particular action right you
know Aristotle told us that we don't
need a delta to necessarily bring that
up on the other hand insofar as we
perceive action as something
intelligible insofar as we can talk
about it in so far as we can
conceptualize it in so far as we can see
it as purposive vac messica literally
sort of measured to or proportionate to
the end that's vac action there is a
kind of universality to it and so we've
got this interesting interplay between
the particular the single end zone and
the universal the utley allgemeine and
for an organism an actual existing
organism not just an imagined organism
right the movement from the first the
last from the agent to the result which
is the continuance of that agent happens
through single action insofar as it's
merely single it becomes trivial it
becomes meaningless let's see what hegel
actually says here he says purpose of
action and such would not belong to the
organism because purpose of the purpose
siddity of action comes about because of
its character of universality the single
action which is only a means comes
through its singleness under the
category as he says now here's a really
interesting price of a single or
contingent necessity a contingent
necessity a single necessity contingent
necessity jumps out you more quickly as
being something like a
zamora or at the very least a paradox
but single necessity should do that as
well especially if we're thinking in
terms of laws right because laws are
supposed to cover all of the phenomena
not just an individual what else does he
say it's uncontrolled by any law again
because laws are not supposed to admit
evict exceptions we saw all of this in
the force in the understanding section
we've had reinforced to us in the
earlier discussions of law he calls it
an empty activity devoid of content of
its own that's important as well he
doesn't say it's entirely devoid of
content but it's devoid of content of
its own something that would be you know
determinative for it and would stand up
the irony here is that empty activity
devoid of content of its own is
understood for the thing that is single
I ends up on its own right so it lacks
by being totally isolated out which is
the perspective that we're often tempted
to take as observing reason we
trivialize we exhaust we suck out the
meaning of things he goes on and he says
it becomes something merely immediate
qua immediate and it contrasts it and
compares it against two other things
your organism in this case is not even
like a machine because every machine
insofar as it's a machine has a
teleology to it it is some sort of
purposiveness not a purposiveness that
it understands itself but a
purposiveness that the maker of the
machine put into it that's why it's a
machine even if it's just a letter right
the other thing that he compares it to
is the actions of acids and bases which
just do what they do and you know if you
want to go further and ask well why do
they do what they do you know you can
get a chemical explanation and you can
keep on pushing it further and further
down but at a certain level using it
answers the way it is that's just what
happens and there
isn't any sort of greater
intelligibility in terms of why things
have to be the way they are quasi all of
you right so what is going on here this
appears around Matt doesn't it we now
street seemingly lost sight of what was
really interesting about organisms he
goes out he says the thing whose
activity is under consideration here is
positive as a thing that preserves
itself in relation to its opposite that
is going to be the lead include to take
us out of here the activity of such is
nothing but the pure essence lyst form
that's being for self its substance
which is not merely a determinate being
with the universal where its end does
not fall outside of it so he was saying
yes we can split these perspectives off
but the action really does have both of
these characters to it that splitting
off is in a certain way something
artificial that that's occurring so he
goes anime says it's an activity which
spontaneously returns to itself is not
turned back into itself anything into it
and now it sounds like we're back on
track with organisms that are the ends
in themselves not in a catchment way but
but if you know the way that they keep
themselves going through their own
activity but there should be rather
troublesome this this fact that when we
do separate law off the individual as
individual and their action the
self-preserving action suddenly it seems
to lose any sort of real determinate
pneus that can assess it e that it has
is merely a contingent necessity so
let's see where he goes from here that
however this unity of universality and
the activity does not exist for this
observing consciousness because that
unity is essentially the inner movement
of the organism and can only be grasped
as notion but observation seeks the
moments in the form of being of enduring
being and because the nature of what is
organically a whole is such that the
moments are not contained in it nor can
be found in it in that form
consciousness converts the antithesis
into one that conforms to its point of
view
paragraph 261 is very short and in it he
is sort of bringing together the
movement that has happened in the last
several paragraphs not only the ones
contained in this particular commentary
video but the paragraphs before that as
well and he's talking about what is
grasped from the position of observing
consciousness I should probably put in
here so you know I've been mentioning
that what's going on is observing reason
is being watched by the phenomenologist
just who is not only observing what
observing reason is doing but also what
observing reason is not catching and
that's what what Hagel is talking about
here so he says that this unity of
universality and the activity right what
is this universe this is unity up it's a
unity of the you might say perspective
of purpose and the perspective of the
single beings the organisms activity
self-preservation these are actually
unified but observing consciousness ends
up splitting them apart into two
different aspects and isn't really
satisfied of either because with the
universality grasping the purpose it
loses hold on the single ba and grasping
the activity as we just saw in the
previous paragraph it loses hold on the
meeting the purposiveness of it and you
know what's what's the issue well it's
trying to grasp them in terms of the
enduring being or like it could hear a
static perspective right now why is it
doing some higgles not not spelling this
out at this point but this is the
difference between say a philosophy of
the understand
and they had a philosophy of the concept
keep that in the back of your mind as we
move through all this Hagel says that
the universality and the action or the
activity are have to be grasped as a
notion as a concept does it be great
right he says observer observation seeks
them in the form of enduring being
because the nature of what is
organically a hole is such that such
that the moments are not contained in it
or it could be found in that form
consciousness converts this antithesis
our opposition into one that conforms to
its point of view and thereby you might
say falsifies it what's really going on
is that there's a dynamic inner movement
involved in every organism in every
organic being and that is what observing
reason has not yet grasped its being
posed to it it has a sort of scandal or
stumbling block although as we're going
to see there's going to now be an
attempt to try to make sense of this